wenn ein ungeborenes kind ein mensch es
von anfang an mit menschenrechten dann
gibt es keine rechtfertigung dieses
leben zu beenden was berechtigt uns dazu
dieses menschen leben einfach ja zur
disposition zu stellen weil du genau an
dieser stelle das menschenrecht und das
menschenleben über das leben der mutter
stellen ein
doch das tust du nein herzlich
willkommen schön dass ihr alle da seid
ich weiß dass es für china ein
emotionales thema von euch ihr seid ja
alle auf irgendeiner art und weise
getroffen aber es ist trotzdem auch wenn
es eine talkrunde ist es ist eine
spielerische talk und hat deswegen hoffe
ich das ja auch ein bisschen spaß haben
bestanden direkt mit unserer konflikt
frage unserer ersten frage ist
abtreibung ein grundrecht wenn ihr sagt
er ja dann geht hier auf das grüne feld
und wenn er sagt er nein kein grund
reicht dann aus katy die position hier
sind klar abtreibungen in deutschland
sind verboten
wusstet ihr dass haben tatsächlich ganz
viele auf dem schirm liegt vielleicht
daran dass in deutschland immer noch
rund 100.000 schwangerschaften pro jahr
abgebrochen werden das geht dann unter
bestimmten bedingungen wenn diese
erfüllt sind
die frage ist sollte der staat sich auf
diese art in das selbstbestimmungsrecht
der frau einmischen können um
ungeborenes leben zu schützen oder
sollte jeder mensch selbst entscheiden
dürfen ob er eine schwangerschaft
abbrechen möchte oder nicht das
diskutieren wir hier heute bei 310
fragen
ab jetzt heißt es wenn ihr einem
argument oder einer frage von mir oder
der anderen seite zustimmt dann geht er
einen schritt nach vorne also ins
nächste kästchen wenn ihr vielleicht
sogar sauer seit und das während die man
anders rede zum ausdruck bringen wollt
dann könnt ihr auch einfach nach hinten
gehen und mein ziel ist es heute
natürlich euch möglichst weit nach vorne
hier ist kompromiss feld zu bringen das
heißt um so mehr ihr euch bewegt umso
besser für mich und mache ich möchte
gerne mit dir anfangen
du hast eine abtreibung schon hinter dir
kannst du vielleicht mal kurz für uns
erklären warum du dich dafür entschieden
aus also ich kannte aber tatsächlich
finde ich spielen die gründe gar keine
rolle
also es war persönliche gründe und ich
finde aber nicht dass es in dieser
diskussion relevant ist generell
spielen die gründer einer frau keine
rolle bei einer abtreibung
wie ist dieses thema total wichtig
einerseits aus persönlichen gründen weil
ich eine persönliche geschichte die es
zu haben und andererseits weil es
einfach ein tabuthema ist und viele
frauen tatsächlich von diesem thema
betroffen sind und wenn wir nicht
darüber reden
dann können wir das thema nicht ein
stigmatisieren und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass man es von meiner seite aus
den anfang zu machen bin nach wie vor
der überzeugung dass es total wichtig
ist dass ich selbst bestimmt über meinen
körper entscheiden kann ob ich mich dazu
befähigt fühle eine mutter zu werden
eine mutterschaft überhaupt trotz die
für mich überhaupt in frage kommt oder
nicht und zu dem damaligen zeitpunkt
haben es für mich auf gar keinen fall in
frage
und es ist auch sicherlich eine
entscheidung die ich nie bereut haben
und du hast damals in einem podcast
matcha latte da ganz offen darüber
gesprochen mit einer parteikollegin du
hast damals auch gesagt dass es für dich
ein bisschen komisch ist da jetzt
öffentlich darüber zu reden weil es ein
sehr tabuisiertes thema ist wie ist es
denn jetzt hier so und so einer runde
darüber zu reden also ich würde generell
sagen dass ich ein sehr offener mensch
bin und ich hab ich spreche generell
gerne bei tabuthemen weil ich finde die
meisten themen gerade themen die uns
frauen betreffen sind extrem tabuisiert
stigmatisiert und deswegen finde ich es
wichtig über die eigenen erfahrungen zu
sprechen und noch das habe ich auch in
meinem podcast getan oder tust nach wie
vor es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich dann
das auf mein profil schreibe oder ich
heiße ich mich vorstelle mit hallo ich
bin mit 32 jahre und habe abgetrieben
das natürlich nicht aber ich finde schon
offenen umgang der gesellschaft mit
diesen themen extrem wichtig ihr habt
euch gerade alle drei nach vorne bewegt
ich wollte euch nämlich gerade fragen
wie ihr zu dem steht was man gerade
gesagt habt ihr seid ihr alle auf der
gegenseite also ich kann einiges von dem
was man gesagt hat auf jeden fall
unterstützen
ich finde beispielsweise das der grund
keine rolle spielen sollte es gibt in
meinen augen gar keinen guten grund fürs
töten es gibt prinzipiell kein gutes
töten sondern töten ist immer ein akt
der gewalt und wir wissen natürlich auch
dass bei einem bei als das bei einer
abtreibung ein ungeborenes kind stirbt
und dann darf der grund warum dieses
kind sterben soll eigentlich erst mal
gar keine rolle spielen der ist
irrelevant darf ich da gleich mal rein
gretchen an welchem punkt setzt du denn
dann das leben überhaupt an abtreibung
sollte meiner meinung nach ein
grundrecht sein weil es ansonsten das
selbstbestimmungsrecht der frau verletzt
mir persönlich liegt dieses thema sehr
am herzen weil ich genau von diesen
abtreibungsgegnern angeklagt worden bin
deswegen möchte ich dass dieses thema
weiter in der öffentlichkeit bleibt da
bin ich ganz naturwissenschaftlich
orientierte leben fängt da an wo das
bundesverfassungsgericht ansetzt wo es
dabei im embryonenschutzgesetz ansetzt
wo die naturwissenschaft her geht und
sagt ab dem punkt ist menschliches leben
und das ist der punkt wo und samenzelle
miteinander verschmelzen
ab dem fängt das leben an auch diese
befruchtete eizelle hat das potenzial so
ein mensch zu werden wie sie
beispielsweise es sei denn ich setze dem
vorzeitig ein ende ist es auch sehr
wichtig hier mit zu diskutieren weil ich
denke dass es eine große chance ist das
bewusstsein dafür nochmal in die mitte
der bevölkerung zu tragen frauen haben
ihr echt eine last zu tragen und wir
lassen sie viel zu viel damit allein und
wir lassen auch die kinder alleine um
die es geht die ja ein recht auf leben
haben und die wir einfach bedenken
müssen und um das noch mal richtig
deutlich zu machen um noch mal zu sagen
mensch wir haben hier in gesellten
gesellschaftliches eine
gesellschaftliche aufgabe als gesamte
gesellschaft dafür bin ich hier
darüber was er als beginn des lebens
definiert oder nicht darüber sprechen
wir später noch mal ich würde gerne mal
über macher jetzt konkret sprechen dann
würdest du also mit dem was du gerade
gesagt hat cornelia quasi sagen mascha
hätte ein embryo umgebracht oder hat
etwas getötet wie würdest du das war man
ja das war der arzt erst gemacht hat
also hast du das ist aber ich glaube
dass auch unstrittig dass das ist etwas
was auch christina hebel in ihrem buch
ist das unstrittig würde ich einer
schafft also ich würde schon sagen das
waren aktive akt von mir also ich sehe
da jetzt nicht den arzt oder die ärztin
in der verantwortung ja wissen dass
sicherlich eine geschichte wo man sagt
dass stehen beide dahinter ein arzt der
das aus führt aber auch die person bzw
eben die frau die gesagt hat das center
hat man kann ja die verantwortung nicht
einfach umlagern auch die ärzte also die
entscheidung habe ich ja getroffen das
ist richtig so kann er bis
abtreibungsgegnerinnen und das mutter
von drei kindern
hast du jemals und deiner persönlichen
geschichte mit deiner familie
mit den kindern darüber nachgedacht
abzutreiben nein ich habe nie aktiv
darüber nachgedacht abzutreiben aber es
gibt natürlich situationen in denen man
sagt also bei mir beispielsweise ich bin
mit 42 das dritte mal schwanger geworden
das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt die
situation wo man sagt tore habe ich mir
jetzt genau so gewünscht das dritte kind
mit 42 und insofern kann ich das
unheimlich gut nachvollziehen wenn
frauen sagen ist jetzt schwer schaffe
ich nicht aber das was für mich ganz
wichtig gewesen ist das sind einfach so
die reaktion im umfeld gewesen dass ich
gemerkt habt mir haben sich ganz viele
hände ausgestreckt da gab es niemand der
gesagt hat was willst du denn jetzt noch
mit einem dritten kind lass das weg
machen sondern es gab lauter leute die
gesagt haben ist doch toll wir freuen
uns mit dir wir unterstützen dich und in
dem moment habe ich gemerkt dass alle
sorgen und ängste auch einfach so von
einem fallen können und das sind ich
unheimlich wichtig deswegen denke ich
dass es deine botschaft die wir in die
gesellschaft tragen müssen dass er schon
auch ein privileg zu sagen man hat einen
partner eine partnerin die eine familie
mann hat freundinnen die das
unterstützen also jetzt habe ich
persönlich sagen wir mal das ganz
alleine gewesen
also ich denke es gibt viele frauen die
da unheimlich stark sind und wir
unterschätzen das potenzial das in
frauen drin ist gerade auch bei ganz
jungen frauen bin ich an unsere beratung
denke ich wir hatten gerade im letzten
jahren fall von einem mädchen die bei 16
und die hat sich entschieden das kind zu
bekommen obwohl sie gesagt hat das war
es war ein akt der gewalt also sie hat
das auch überhaupt nicht gewollt und die
hat eine stärke in sich gefunden und
aufgebaute dieses jahr zu finden zu dem
kind das fand ich sensationell
und wenn das umfeld nicht da ist dann
ist es unsere aufgabe dafür zu sorgen
dass wir dieses umfeld schaffen und das
machen wir mit unserer organisation
beispielsweise ganz minute anfangen die
frauen am anfang ab und wir stellen
ihnen eine patin zur verfügung für neun
monate die sie dann weiter begleitet um
dieses umfeld das vielleicht nicht ja
sagt zum kind zu ersetzen und zu sagen
wir liefern euch die unterstützung die
er braucht ihr könnt euch jetzt gern
dazu positionieren stehen bleiben nur
ein schritt auf sie zu gerne sagen das
finde ich großartig dass ihr das macht
das ist unumwunden aber ich kann ja nur
sagen als
ärztin die abtreibungen durchführt und
die sehr viele schicksale bzw
frauengeschichten dazu gehört hat und
auch erklärt bekommen hat ich lasse mir
im gegensatz zu jetzt du möchtest es
nicht sagen aber ich spreche schon mit
den frauen darüber was ihre beweggründe
sind ich finde das ist eine extrem
idealistische vorstellung dass jede frau
eine kraft eine stärke entwickelt dass
jede frau aufgefangen werden kann dass
jede frau ein total tolles soziales
umfeld hat wo ihr die hände gereicht
werden ich kann nur sagen das ist schön
dass es dir so ergangen ist aber da bist
du in meinen augen komplett weltfremd
weil das die masse und viele andere das
ist definitiv anders und aber ich kann
wirklich nur sagen das finde ich
wirklich vermessen zu sagen dass frauen
immer die stärke entwickeln dass es
immer ein gutes umfeld dass man viel
helfen kann
das ist nicht und das ist ja auch
faktisch nicht so überhaupt faktisch
überhaupt gar nicht so 90 prozent der
alleinerziehenden sind frauen und
doppelt so viele sind von armut
betroffen oder gefährdet wie die normale
durchschnittsbevölkerung und dazu sagen
okay man hat ein einfaches umfeld ist
auch einfach faktisch falsch sabina du
bist ein schritt nach vorne gegangen ich
bin absolut deiner meinung aber ich bin
absolut der meinung dass das nicht das
problem der frau ist sondern das problem
der gesellschaft
unsere gesellschaft ist nicht mutter
freundlich ist nicht frauenfreundlich
und die verantwortung wird hier auch die
frau abgewälzt
abtreibung ist von ihrem wesen her die
beendigung eines menschlichen lebens und
ich finde dass das nicht so ein
grundrecht werden kann denn ohne das
recht auf leben sind alle anderen rechte
obsolet egal ob sie sich für das kind
entscheidet oder ob sie sich gegen das
kind entscheidet die verantwortung liegt
am ende bei der frau und dass wir eine
gesellschaft haben dass wir in
deutschland eine gesellschaft haben wo
mutter werden ein armutsrisiko ist es
ist ein skandal
wir haben sich drei leute auf dich zu
bewegt michael du was sagst du dazu
also etwas das ihr euch zu uns bewegt
aber deswegen ist ja so gut macht was du
gesagt hat es dass solche tabus nicht
sein sollen
deswegen ist auch super dass wir über so
ein thema ins gespräch kommen und dass
man so sachen auch mitdiskutiert und
auftakt und in der tat das ist ein
riesengroßes problem ich denke schon
dass auch wenn diese gesellschaftliche
probleme immens sind doch durchaus auch
im umfeld öfter da ist es vielleicht auf
den ersten blick sieht und manches wenn
wenn auch ein kind erst mal da ist
manches steckt ja auch um ihn dann doch
unterstützung was mir als arzt besonders
wichtig ist es einmal ein bisschen
einblick zu vermitteln in die
faszination das noch nicht geborenen
lebens haben des kindes wie sich ja
schon so faszinierend entwickelt vor der
geburt weil das fliegen in der regel nur
ärzte oder psychologen mit und andere
ist allerdings auch darauf aufmerksam zu
machen wie wie brutal und grausam auch
eine abtreibung ist wie dir abläuft und
auch ein fürsprecher sein zu wollen für
die schwächsten für die die sonst keine
fürsprecher haben nämlich für den noch
nicht geborenen kinder und für deren
leben schutz den ich immens wichtig
findet er
du hast vor einigen jahren gemeinsam mit
deiner freundin sich dazu entschieden
einen schwangerschaftsabbruch
vorzunehmen und du beschreibst aber
diesen eingriff als dramatische
entscheidung warum wir waren damals
anfang mitte 20 und die überlegung
dahinter standen waren wirtschaftlich
ich habe noch studiert sie war gerade
zwei wochen im neuen job zu einer zeit
wo es noch nicht den schutz für
schwangere auch in der probezeit gab das
heißt das dass dieser job endet war
absehbar und die die die ängste wieder
hochkamen war kann ich mein kind
ernähren kann ich mit meinem kind das
bieten was mir geboten wurde kann ich
kann ich diese verantwortung tragen bin
ich in der lage als vater meine familie
zu ernähren meine familie zu beschützen
also es waren ganz viele eng
die aus dem inneren hochkamen und
aufgrund dessen ist am ende dieser
entscheidung getroffen worden meiner
meinung nach darf eine frau
grundsätzlich natürlich selbst darüber
entscheiden ob sie eine schwangerschaft
abbricht oder nicht und darf natürlich
über ihren eigenen körper entscheiden
und was ich heute kritisiere ist das bei
den psychologischen gesprächen im
vorfeld nur sie dabei war ich als mann
aber nicht einbezogen wurde
und ich habe auch für mich am ende
gemerkt das ist ein eingriff in den
körper der frau das ist gar keine frage
und darüber darf sie am ende entscheiden
aber was ist mit mir als vater gemacht
hat in dem moment als ich in der praxis
saß während dieser abtreibung wusste ich
es war die falsche entscheidung so
schnell schon in dem moment wurde mir
ein stück herausgerissen und das war
mein kind und das war für mich
traumatisch genauso wie für sie für sie
auch körperlich aber die seelische die
emotional traumatisierung war sehr krass
und dementsprechend versuche ich immer
oder rede ich deshalb öffentlich darüber
umso bisschen die männer auch mit rein
zu nehmen weil die stecken mit in der
verantwortung ganz klar und sie stecken
aber auch mit in dem in dem körper und
der seele dieses kindes und ich finde es
wichtig dass man und vor allem dass
paare und dass am ende die frau ist
eigenmächtig bestimmen darf weil ich
glaube wenn man etwas tabuisiert und
komplett verbietet finden menschen immer
wege dann gehe ich über die grenze ins
ausland wo es machbar ist oder am ende
führt zu selbstverletzungen oder zu ganz
schlimme sachen also wenn ich dinge
komplett verbietet finden menschen die
angst und panik haben und denken oh mein
gott was macht dieses kind mit meinem
leben ich schaffe das nicht die finden
einen weg der dann halt illegal ist und
ich glaube da darf man auffangen und da
darf man beraten da darf man coachen da
darf man psychologisch rangehen und
diese menschen auffangen und auch
vielmehr den partner auch mit einbinden
gerade das was du gesagt hast eben
dieses auffangnetz der mann ist ja da
und viele männer werden so ist ja nicht
dein körper was hast du damit zu tun
ich glaube den männern ist es nicht
bewusst und viele frauen trauen sich
auch nicht den man mal dazu zu nehmen
und ich glaube wir dürfen da auch den
männern in der gesellschaft zeigen da
ist auch dein kind und egal wie es dazu
kam du hattest du einen anteil
und da darfst du auch mit verantwortung
übernehmen aber ich hätte ihm eine
wichtige frage und zwar was hätte es
gebraucht damit ihr ja sagt zu dem kind
was hat gefehlt bewusstsein und meine
meine persönliche entwicklung mein mann
stand war komplett im außen finanziell
wie mache ich das schaffe ich das traue
ich mir das zu kann ich meinem kind das
ermöglichen was es braucht als familie
als vater ich bin selber vater seit 20
monaten ich weiß eine sache kinder
brauchen eine einzige sache und das ist
liebe eine einzige sache und das ist
liebe es wir haben so ein bisschen viele
heute unterstützen er ist vielleicht
gegangen oder mit sicherheit wäre es
gegangen es wäre auf jeden fall gegangen
darum darum wusste ich auch in dem
moment das war falsch es hat im
endeffekt weiß ich was es in mir
ausgelöst hat welche entwicklung wofür
es gut war am ende und ändern kann ich
zurückblicken sowieso nicht mehr
aber mit meinem wissen und meine
entwicklung von heute hätte ich damals
anders entschieden aber wenn ich es
damals besser gewusst hätte hätte ich
besser gemacht also diese ambivalenz die
du vorhin gesagt hat dass kann ich total
gut verstehen und ich glaube das ist ein
ganz vielen lebenssituationen die
herausfordernd sind dass man so nah wie
über lenz hat aber dann gerade denke ich
ist es so wichtig ermutigung zu erfahren
und natürlich ist das für jemanden der
jetzt 18 oder oder 15 ist oder 20
natürlich noch herausfordernder das will
ich überhaupt nicht in abrede stellen
aber er aber umso besser für dich
ermutigung das kind auf jeden fall zu
kriegen nicht ermutigung eine innere
stärke eine innere haltung zu finden
na ja deine haltung geht er davon aus
die einzig richtige entscheidung zu dem
ich diese frau ist ermutigen darf ist
das kind zu kriegen und das ist halt
sehr sehr plakativ und vor allem sehr
sehr einseitig ja aber möchte dazu sagen
mit darf das sind halt schwierige
vokabeln ich möchte halt nur in dem
punkt auch wie du sagtest vielleicht war
so ein bisschen mehr räumen dabei aber
das kind dass dieses kind damals als du
20 was lebt ja nicht mehr da will ich
auch niemanden ein schlechtes gewissen
machen nur es ist auch so dass das
ungeborene kind und nicht geborene kind
braucht auch einen fürsprecher und das
finde ich wichtig das finde ich auch für
mich als arzt werden so dass dieses kind
auf ein fürsprecher hat
und dass diese seite auch beleuchtet
wird weil dieses kind kann er nicht für
sich sprechen das kann nicht seinen mund
aufmachen sagen ich möchte aber gerne
leben ich möchte auch wenn mein vater
nicht ganz perfekt ist und noch
herausforderung hat oder wenn meine
mutter vielleicht noch nicht die
perfekte liebe schenken kann aber peter
entwickelt sich das kann das kind ja
nicht sagen aber das finde ich halt
wichtig hier auch als fürsprecher zu
fungieren zu dem thema recht also die
gesetzeslage ist immer noch ganz
deutlich dass abtreibung immer noch als
straftat gilt es gibt die paragrafen 218
und 219 bettina du zum beispiel wurde es
zu einer geldstrafe verurteilt weil du
auf deiner homepage darüber informiert
hat dass die schwangerschafts abbrüche
zu den leistungen zählen
du setzt dich genau dafür ein dass eben
du das aber weiterhin auf deiner
homepage schreiben darfst warum warum
ist das wichtig dafür zu kämpfen warum
stehst jetzt hier auf dem spielfeld weil
weil ich ganz klar als grund richter
frau sehr darüber zu entscheiden ob sie
eine schwangerschaft aus trägt oder
nicht
und dazu gehört es auch dass ich als
arzt darüber oder als ärztin darüber
informieren kann dass ich diesen abbruch
oder diese geschichte durchführe und
auch darüber schreiben darf und das ist
ja jetzt ein bisschen in der zankapfel
wie wie ich diesen abbruch durchführe
weil das ist ja nach wie vor nicht
erlaubt das wird ja dann quasi als
werbung bezeichnet bezeichnet wenn du
auf deiner seite schreibst ich biete das
um das an diese und jene techniken jetzt
mal aus seiner perspektive was ist denn
für dich werbung war war dass werbung
was du auf deiner seite natürlich nicht
sondern es war eine sachliche
information darüber dass ich diesen
eingriff durchführen und auch auf welche
art und weise ich den durchführen
das ist ein übliches prozedere das auf
den webseiten von ärztinnen draufsteht
was für leistungen sie anbieten welche
medizinischen leistungen sie anbieten
und ich sehe überhaupt keinen grund
warum ich eine sachliche information
nicht darüber auch auf meiner webseite
haben also ich denke es halt nicht eine
leistung wie andere auch ob ich jetzt
darüber informieren welche operation
nicht anbiete welche art und weise
dann ist das natürlich was anderes
medizinisches was was ein ganz anderes
spektrum abdeckt als jetzt eben
abtreibung dir jetzt eben auch
unrecht sind oder nicht erlaubt sind und
deswegen denke ich sollte man da schon
unterscheiden
und es ist ja auch nicht so wenn jemand
anruft kann die information der
weitergegeben werden
anrufe wenn ja wir haben auch staaten
stellen wenn er dazu entschlossen ist
und eine eine abtreibung möchte muss
nicht erst an einen telefon ran sondern
er kann ja gucken an welcher stelle
sitzt der und der arzt ist das in der
nähe welche art der methode bietet er an
da bin ich überhaupt nicht mit dir da
chor das ist ja klar das ist aus deiner
aus deiner sicht mag das sein dass das
keine leistung ist wie die wie eine
andere auch weil weil das bei dir ganz
klar dass du bist ein bist möchtest du
schwitzt
das kann ich für meine seite so in der
form nicht sagen also kann ich auch dass
auf meiner
aber ich habe da muss man da einfach
noch mal gute sondern kann auch einfach
das wär § 209 10 als auch dahin geändert
worden dass ich das jetzt sagen darf ja
weil es natürlich keine werbung ist
unter dem das steht also ja wir wollen
einfach mal gucken warum hat der
gesetzgeber das überhaupt gemacht es
gibt ja ein grund dafür dass wir diesen
219 a ha und sieg und heller und weißt
du auf 60 seiten getroffen ist dass wir
sagen eine abtreibung ist in deutschland
nicht legal
sie ist unter bestimmten bedingungen
strafbar so also habe ich ja ein
straftatbestand
und wenn ich jetzt her gehe und sage als
gesetzgeber und du darfst aber für den
straftatbestand werbung machen dann kann
ich auch noch steuerberater sagen er
darf auf seiner website angeben dass er
in sachen steuerhinterziehung bereits
etwas stimmt zu einen daumen ist das
hamburg house mal diesen paragraphen als
weitere sogenannten klimaschutz
paragrafen behält um zu sagen wir müssen
dieses unrechtsbewusstsein im bezug auf
die abtreibung wenigstens rudimentär in
der gesellschaft erhalten es muss den
menschen bewusst bleiben dass hier ein
kind getötet wird und da können wir
nicht hergehen und sagen und der arzt
erst macht der darf damit auch noch
werben das geht nicht also ich fühle
mich komplett
ich fühle mich damit komplett
angegriffen das ist keine form der
werbung sondern das ist eine sachliche
information über ein eingriff der der in
deutschland straffrei ist um das gericht
hat auch entschieden des gesetzes
geändert worden dass man das jetzt darf
ich darf nur nicht sagen
wie ich es tue aber der gesetzgeber hat
ganz klar die jetzt zurückrudert und hat
ja auch den paragraf novelliert würde
mich auch interessieren was ihr dazu
denkt findet ihr diese paragrafen
sollten abgeschafft werden oder auf
jeden fall bleiben schreibt mir die
kommentare
sabina ich würde gerne auf dich zu
sprechen kommen du sagst nämlich das
leben das beginnt mit der zeugung und
aus auch ein podcast gestartet um mit
vorurteilen gegenüber lebensschützer in
aufzuräumen warum liegt ihr dann das
thema so doll am herzen dass im podcast
maß dass sich hier gerade auf dem feld
ist ich finde ja ich finde tatsächlich
dass das lebensrecht des menschen mit
der zeugung beginnt und ich finde es
ich finde es absurd dass da ein grund
eine gültigkeit hat dieses leben zu
beenden
und vor allem ist es eine konsistente
und eine kohärente lebens ethik wenn man
sich diese ethik bis zum ende durch
denkt dann kann man das komplett ohne
glauben machen es gibt sehr viele
lebensschützer die gläubig sind ich bin
aber auch glaube ich aber das ist nicht
allein die grundlage meiner haltung das
ist eine konsistente und kohärente ethik
die allein auf humanistischen werten
auch passieren kann und ich möchte das
auch transportieren dass es nicht
einfach alles irgendwelche komischen
spinner sind sondern dass wir ganz
normale vernünftige menschen sind und
dass es sinn macht das zu sagen wenn ein
wenn ein ungeborenes kind ein mensch es
von anfang an mit menschenrechten dann
gibt es keine rechtfertigung dieses
leben zu beenden wenn es das nicht ist
dann könnte man sagen dann braucht keine
rechtfertigung wenn es kein mensch ist
okay dann dann ist es klar dann brauchen
wir dafür keine rechtfertigung aber wenn
es um menschenleben ist das berechtigt
uns dazu dieses menschen leben einfach
ja zur disposition zu stellen weil du
genau an dieser stelle das menschenrecht
und das menschenleben über das leben der
mutter stellen ein
doch das tust du nein und zwar indem du
ganz klar sagt dieser ungeborene mensch
hat das gleiche recht wie die mutter und
du stellst es sogar über ist weil du
stirbst sozusagen das recht des kindes
über über das über das recht der
werdenden mutter rein meine aus auch
eindeutig in einem podcast die mutter
und das kind sind gleich wertvoll haben
die gleiche würde ja und die gleichen
menschenrechte es sind hier nicht mehr
die gegeneinander abzuwägen sind sondern
rechte und in allen anderen fällen ist
es klar dass das selbstbestimmungsrecht
da endet wo das lebensrecht des anderen
beginnt
ich finde es wichtig dass wir da ein
bisschen von der emotionalen ebene
herunter gehen weil es ist eigentlich
eine rationale sei es sache von vernunft
und die die emotionale seite ist total
wichtig menschen sind aber emotionale
wesen und jascha wird auf emotionen du
kannst vor allem so etwas niemals auf
eine rein rationale ebene ziel ist es
pure emotionen das ist nicht meine
aussage dass wir gesetzgebung nicht auf
emotion passieren können wir können
dieses thema absolut menschlich
betrachten und ich wollten sich groß ist
aber die vielleicht fliegen dann stücke
zu ende schreiben orientieren die die
gesetzgebung hat sich in erster linie an
den menschenrechten an der würde des
menschen zu orientieren und am der würde
des existierenden und wie kannst du aber
die frage der mensch ich will dass du
die würde eines ungeborenen kindes
schützen
das im körper einer frau steckt dass es
ablehnt dass es nicht will dass am ende
schlecht mit dem kind umgeht während der
schwangerschaft raucht läuft und alles
tut um am ende vielleicht dieses kind
dann auf natürlichem wege zu verlieren
werde nicht sind gesundheitlich
geschädigt kommt schwer behindert auf
die welt
berlin seine models ablehnt und weil er
nicht die möglichkeit gegeben wo die
schwangerschaft zu bekommen ja nicht
weiter wenn wir nur diese extreme
position betrachtet hat extrem was wir
auf gar keinen fall machen dürfen ist
hergehen und sagen wir setzen hier in
deutschland ist recht des stärkeren
durch die mutter die schwanger es ist
die stärkere und das der das kind das
ungeborene der schwächeren position der
schnee aufgabe des staates ist den
schwächeren zu schützen und deswegen
haben wir diese gesetzgebung dass das
ist grundlage unserer gesellschaft der
staat hat den schwächeren zu schützen
gegen die über griffigkeit des anderen
und das was hier passiert bei abtreibung
das ist jetzt das ist nicht
selbstbestimmung das ist fremdbestimmung
hier habe ich eine frau die über einen
fremden körper nämlich den körper ihres
kindes fremdbestimmt und sagt du darfst
nicht leben weil ich glaube ich kann ich
eventuell nicht lieben ich musste kurz
ist aber ich muss da kurz zu
unterbrechen wahrscheinlich wird
interessieren was denkst du denn dazu
für mich ist ganz eindeutig die lebende
frau wichtiger ihre selbstbestimmung
steht in meinen augen über der
befruchtung
die also wo ich sagen würde ob das jetzt
schon ein mensch ist also wo fängt
männchen leben an
ich glaube die fraglos man sich generell
mal stellen und ich glaube da haben wir
schon herzlich ganz klar geht und da
haben wir schon auf jeden fall
kompromiss gefunden mit dem fenster das
halte ich auch für dich lenkt ab der
zwölften schwangerschaftswoche
für mich fängt ganz ehrlich gesagt noch
viel später an für mich persönlich so
wie ich das verstehe braucht es um
schmerz zu finden braucht es rezeptoren
nerven bahn braucht es braucht es ein
gehirn was diesen schmerz warum hat es
dennoch nichts kann der ein bisschen auf
einen lassen ganz kurz aussprechen und
es gibt und dass es dazu auch noch
braucht ist ein bewusstsein und das ist
glaube ich erst ab der was dreißigsten
schwangerschaftswoche frühestens
insofern am anfang für mich zumindest
ist das in zwei haufen also da will ich
jetzt aber doch noch mal dazwischen
gehen wollen weil zellhaufen sind wir
alle nur wir sind halt größere zellen
hafen und nicht nicht so kleine aber
welcher zellzahlen fängt dann neben
einer arbeit und das hast du sagtest er
noch kurz möchte ich auch gerne ausreden
dass das du sagtest bewusstsein oder
gehirn oder diese ganzen einzelnen
stufen da sind keine stufen eine
kontinuierliche entwicklung von anfang
an wo es nicht einzelne stufen rein
medizinisch doch es gibt oder einen
laptop und ein kind in der elften woche
hat er jetzt keinen anderen wert oder
keine anderen fähigkeiten wie ein kind
jetzt in der dreizehnten woche oder in
der 20 das ist kontinuierlich auch das
schmerzempfinden ist nicht etwas schlag
so und soviel der woche ist es da
sondern es entwickelt sich von anfang an
wo die ersten normalen zellen sich
entwickeln dann werden nervenbahnen
gebildet dann bildet sich wirbelsäulen
und rücken und gehören und so weiter und
das ist ein politischer prozess der auch
noch nach der geburt weitergeht auch ein
kind auch die geburt ist relativ
willkürlich ich meine lunge ist erst im
siebten lebensjahr ausländische ließen
und würden auf kein ergebnis kommen wo
wir alle einer meinung sind wann beginnt
leben und ich glaube auch dass das gut
dafür dass das für die diskussion dass
fragst du zehn wissenschaftler kriegst
du auch zehn meinungen wahrscheinlich so
fragt so 10
emotion aber nochmal
gelmer bettina fragen wie wo fängt das
dann für dich an also es hat ja schon
die meisten von euch haben ja schon
gesagt dass ich euch anfängen bisher
aber das ist ja gut aber da kommen wir
jetzt ja wieder tatsächlich in sehr
radikale positionen ich meine wie kann
ich in einer klinik eine spätabtreibung
durchführen bei einem
schwerstbehinderten beziehungsweise kind
was jetzt irgendwie ein wahrscheinlich
über unter umständen die geburt nicht
überleben will und damit wird damit
komplett tief 0 frau und mutter
überfordert und traumatisiert dann würde
ich ja dann an dieser stelle wäre ich
auf jeden fall eine einer mörderin in
euren duktus egal auf welcher woche das
wäre also ich meine egal an welcher
stelle meine abtreibung macht wir sind
immer mörder in euren aus allerdings
keiner gesagt so was worte wenn der so
nicht in den schmutz und samenzelle
zusammengehen das dann schon schon schon
das töten eines eines kindes ist ja dann
ist es doch ein halbes jahr keine gibt's
doch gar keine frage aber das ist ja die
alte frage für mich beginnt es in dem
augenblick wo das kind tatsächlich den
den leib der mutter verlässt und wenn es
wenn besondere umstände für eine mutter
nicht erst ermöglicht oder für ein paar
auch ein kind auszutragen aus
psychischen gründen aus verschiedenen
anderen gründen
dann gibt es ja in deutschland
tatsächlich auch diese spätabtreibung
jetzt sagen kann ich mache jetzt mal als
vater was dazu weil das alles ist alles
so technisch und so also ich bin ja nur
vater aber ich habe über 40 wochen
schwangerschaft erlebt wie mein kind
gewachsen ist und das war definitiv
nicht ersten lebewesen als es auf der
welt war und auch nicht erst mit 20 30
wochen sondern du du spürst da
entwickelt sich was du spürst dass
interagiert mit dir das reagiert auf
musik das reagiert auf sprache das
reagiert auf berührungen und die die
beziehung zu meinem sohn hat lange vor
seiner geburt angefangen ja das weiß ich
ganz klar und ganz bewusst ich glaube
dass die die fragestellung wann beginnt
leben bringt uns bei der fragestellung
erlauben oder verbieten wir eine
abtreibung bis zu einer gewissen grenze
und am ende nicht weiterbringt weil egal
wie's radikalisiere in die eine oder in
die andere richtung drängen
in einer situation in der sie sich
vielleicht nicht zu helfen wissen ich
glaube uns zu öffnen uns anzuhören was
bewegt denn die menschen die frau auch
den partner vielleicht und mit diesen
menschen gemeinsam eine eine lösung zu
finden mit der sie leben können am ende
und sich sich dessen bewusst zu machen
dass die entscheidung und die eine wie
in die andere richtung eine enorme
tragweite hat und du diese entscheidung
immer in deinem leben mit dir rum trägst
genau aber da kann doch auch wieder
helfen indem man eben auf die
faszination was da alles schon passiert
hinweis auf dieses wunder wasser
geschieht passiert das nicht in den
beratungsstellen auch intel wäre schön
wenn zu verlieren würde aber dass er
einen riesen großer komplex und auf
diese schönheiten hinzuweisen für die
total wichtig aber auch vorhin war dass
das beispiel ist mit einem
spätabtreibungen von einem behinderten
kind aber da denke ich auch ein
behindertes kind noch ein
schwerbehindertes kind auch das ist ja
total schwierig und das sind ja auch
menschen schicksal um die es geht wenn
ein paar so ein schwer erkranktes kind
hat ja und natürlich kann dann dort nach
rechts sei auch ein test durchgeführt
werden aber es gibt auch da alternativen
die man natürlich besprechen muss und
erst dann läuten auch da bringen muss
das zum beispiel auch ein
schwerbehindertes kind trotzdem zur welt
geboren werden kann und dann in den
armen der mutter verstirbt wenn es dann
nicht lebensfähig ist dann aber auch
schmerzbehandlung bekommen kann dies
sehr im mutterland nie bekommt das und
dann ist eine ganz andere betreuung da
und ich habe schon solche frauen betreut
und die sagten das war so wertvoll auch
wenn die zeit nur wenn die sonne das
eigene ich muss euch gerichtet so
entscheide ich glaub das verbrechen
liebe leid michael die angebote müssen
gemacht werden das ist wichtig die
arbeiten tschuldigung ich muss euch kurz
unterbrechen sonst werden wir hier heute
nie fertig er wird mich ein bisschen
ganz minimal durchlassen
das wäre vielleicht auch eine frage an
euch findet ihr das leben beginnt ab der
zeugung oder erst ab der geburt schreibe
es in die kommentare
ok also werden jetzt ziemlich viele
verschiedene aspekte durchgesprochen und
ihr kommt auch immer wieder zu den
gleichen deswegen würde ich jetzt gern
noch mal einen anderen aspekt besprechen
ihr wollt ihr auch immer nach hause
es wurde hier fünf schon so ein bisschen
irgendwann war angesprochen wo das
eigentliche problem liegt kann es dann
sein dass nicht abtreibung das problem
ist sondern unsere gesellschaft die ja
auch frauen benachteiligt wie siehst du
das
also ich glaube dass spielt sicherlich
eine rolle dass
bestimmtes rollenbild frauen überstülpen
dass frauen bestimmte erwartungen zu
erfüllen haben und dass kinder sehr
häufig einfach nicht mehr in diese
lebensplanung reinpassen
weil gesagt wird du du musst die
ausbildung machen du musst die schule
fertig machen und dann muss zum beruf
ergreifen und amos karriere machen und
kinder kommen irgendwann ganz am schluss
dass es irgendwie so die lebensplanung
die wir im moment haben und uns gelingt
es immer weniger zu sagen wir dass das
frauen ein kind bekommen ist das
normalste von der welt und es
integrieren wir in diese arbeitswelt in
unserem unser umfeld einfach mit ein
also ich würde mir viel mehr arbeitgeber
wünschen und unternehmer die sagen nicht
nur die frauen die schwanger sind
gehören mit zu unserem unternehmen dazu
sondern vor allem auch die frauen die
das kind bekommen haben die über
unglaubliche fähigkeiten verfügen die
die die logistik betreffend erziehung
pädagogik streitschlichter das sind ja
alles sachen die man als mutter lernt
und von denen unternehmen und betriebe
profitieren könnten wenn sie nur bereit
wären herzen gehen und zu sagen gut okay
du warst jetzt vielleicht in der mutter
pause aber ich hole dich da wieder ab
und du bist für unser unternehmen
wertvoll und wenn wir diese haltung
etwas mehr in der gesellschaft forcieren
könnten dann glaube ich hätten frauen an
nicht mehr so viel angst davor ein kind
zu bekommen
ihr seid alle auf cornelia inschrift
zugegangen warum absolut also dass das
ganze thema familie und karriere in
richtung geht die nicht mehr gesund ist
also es ist ja es geht ja immer weiter
dass frauen eingeredet wird du bist nur
wertvoll als mensch und als frau wenn du
karriere machst einfach mutter und
familien mutter zu sein ist nicht mehr
wertvoll genug ich glaube eure
punkteabstand punkte mittlerweile recht
klar geworden
ich habe einen kompromissvorschlag ein
lösungsvorschlag jetzt den ich euch
vortragen werde dann könnt ihr sagen was
ihr dazu denkzettel ein schritt auf mich
zukommen oder stehenbleiben
also ich beginne frauen muss es leichter
gemacht werden ein kind zu bekommen wir
müssen sie per gesetz schützen und
unterstützen und somit auch versuchen
zum beispiel alleinerziehende aus dem
armutsrisiko zu holen
was sagt ihr
alle ein stück nach vorne gegangen
so jetzt dürft ihr jeweils in jeder
gruppe auf jeden fall auch noch ein
kompromiss vorschlag formulieren das
habt ihr ja auch gerade schon so ein
bisschen gemacht habe auch kein konto
ja ich glaube wir sind wiesen
kompromissbereiter als die andere seite
dicht machte die idealvorstellung die
werden wir nicht nicht realistisch
erreichen überhaupt wir jetzt gerade
welt diskutiert wird könnt ihr mir
einmal in den kommentaren schreiben was
wäre neuer alternativer
kompromissvorschlag natürlich willst du
es vortragen oder da finde ich mach du
kannst hier kann man noch mal kurz in
das ist ja richtig was vielleicht dazu
ab jeder von euch jeder seite darf
einmal ihren lösungsvorschlag
vorschlagen der anderen seite davon
erzählen und dann bevor ihr darüber
diskutiert soll sich die andere seite
dazu positionieren entweder sie geht
raus und hat kein bock mehr oder geht
einen schritt auf euch zu deswegen will
ich sagen geht fängt an und dann kommen
wir zu grün
was ist euer vorschlag also auf der
rechtlichen seite können wir nicht nicht
mehr erlauben von unserer seite aus sind
das lebensrecht des kindes ist ja jetzt
schon massiv bedroht aber wir wünschen
uns natürlich eine bessere aufklärung
der frauen auch über das was wirklich
passiert bei einer abtreibung was die
möglichen folgen sind welche welche
möglichkeiten zur hilfe und welche
alternativen da sind da wünschen wir uns
wirklich eine ausgiebige ausführlichen
professionelle beratung und die
möglichkeit zur information natürlich
und auch gleichzeitig wie kerim auch
schon gesagt hat dass die väter stärker
in die verantwortung genommen werden und
geht er einen schritt auf die seite zu
was was das angeht mit der mitte mit der
verantwortung zu übernehmen darf doch da
kann nicht also kann ich persönlich
schon ein stück draufzugehen
ich finde immer dann wenn wir radikal
mit verboten arbeiten finde ich es
schwierig weil das ist das ist sehr
sozialistischer ansatz und das ist
einfach widerspricht meinem meinem
freiheitsliebenden weltbild einfach
komplett ok also ihr bewegt euch gar
nicht auf die andere seite zu
0,5 und 0,6
jetzt würde ich gerne ich würde jetzt
gerne bevor ihr nochmal weiter
diskutiert würde ich jetzt gerne euren
lösungsvorschlag hören also ich bin ganz
dafür dass es ein sicherheitsnetz geben
muss für frauen
ich glaube aber auch dass ein verbot
eine abtreibung steht nicht zur debatte
ich persönlich fordere eben noch mehr
ich fordere eine entkriminalisierung der
abtreibung
das ist ja genau die gegenteilige
position
und deswegen glaube ich kann ein
kompromiss in dem fall nicht stattfinden
die einzige einigung die wir dadurch
finden können ist eben die frauen mütter
familien mehr zu stärken
generell okay ich gehe mal davon aus ihr
geht ich keinen schritt auf sie zu naja
also die vokabel finde ich halt ganz
schwierig mit der kriminalisierung ich
würd's halt definitiv so nehmen wie es
ja auch gedacht jetzt ein schutzgesetz
nach wie vor schutz von anna der schutz
gilt ja dann nicht mehr frauen aber auch
für das kind letzter versuch ein kind
zur adoption freizugeben das immer noch
ein tabuthema das habt ihr alle auch
schon heute angesprochen
sollten wir daher die möglichkeit der
adoption entstigmatisieren stimmt ihm zu
kommt er einen schritt auf mich zu das
wetter ist die frage ist ja du nicht
dann habe ich habe ich ein paar ins
kompromiss feld gebracht ich weiß es ein
sehr schwieriges thema aber es war
trotzdem eine sehr spannende diskussion
ich danke euch allen banken
wie geht es mir ja ich glaube da haben
wir beide jetzt oft bestimmt doch große
probleme weil ich glaube nicht dass wir
auf irgend einen konsens oder auf
irgendeinen kompromiss gekommen sind
ich fühle mich eher unbehaglich jetzt
gerade auch wieder in dieser situation
weil mir dieses plakative und dieses
jahr fast dogmatische immer wieder
gleich hervorbringen der argumentation
der der abtreibungsgegner einfach immer
wieder so vor die füße fällt das ist
dass ich fast ärgerlich werde ich glaube
es gibt bestimmte grundrechte die
brauchen wir in unserer gesellschaft und
eines dieser ganz wichtigen grundrechte
oder dogmen um es mit seinen worten zu
sagen ist eben das grundrecht auf leben
und ich finde es ganz klasse wenn wir
uns darauf einigen könnten dass wir
dieses grundrecht jedem menschen zu
gestehen
das wäre schon mal riesenschritt und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe das
ganz schön gefunden das wir gemerkt
haben in dieser diskussion
es gibt doch eben bereiche wo man sagen
kann ok da finden wir zusammen da sehen
wir hier ist noch handlungsbedarf und
letztendlich glaube ich können wir uns
doch schon dahin einigen dass wir sagen
das kann niemals gut seien einfach einen
menschen zu töten
prinzipiell nicht also ich fand den
austausch prinzipiell spannend ich
glaube sicherlich auch weil ich ihn
selten in berührung komme mit ja
vielleicht menschen geht die dinge
anders sehen als ich also ich bin halt
er in seiner sehr liberalen blase
insofern finde ich natürlich spannend
dann auf andersdenkende zu stoßen
aber um ehrlich zu sein war mir schon im
voraus klar dass es da einfach kein
kompromiss geben kann
das sehe ich genauso jede ist ja immer
so ein bisschen in seiner babbel
unterwegs aber ich fand es trotzdem ich
finde es immer wieder auch spannend und
ich finde es wichtig auch diese insights
in die persönlichen geschichten auch zu
kriegen und einfach die ja den blick zu
weiten führt das für die realität von
abtreibungen sowohl für die frau aber
auch für das kind und für menschen die
das eben anders sehe die das leben des
ungeborenen kindes als schützenswerte
achten
das war eine sehr spannende wichtiger
und wirklich intensive diskussion ist
aufgefallen dass die einzige andere 13
fragen folge dieses wo so hitzig
diskutiert wurde die prostitutions folge
war da muss ich darüber nachdenken das
ja irgendwie komischerweise die themen
die unsere gesellschaft am meisten
spalten die sind die rechte der frauen
betreffen oder also dann hat man
prostitution
das soll den frauen dann dicht machen
weil das passt nicht in unser
gesellschaftliches bild von den frauen
abtreibungen passt auch nicht was
brauchen da machen wollen also irgendwie
geht es immer darum dass wir nicht so
interessant gebe ich euch noch mal zum
nachdenken mit und ansonsten hoffe ich
natürlich dass die folge euch auch
irgendwie zu neuen gedanken inspiriert
hat falls ja lasst doch gerne ein abo
hier da und die prostitution freuen
könnt ihr euch natürlich auch sehr gerne
anschauen hier und hier oben gibt ein
anderes video zum thema